avec deux jeunes gens qui en ont profité
pour faire un doigt d'honneur
cette scène m'a valu au président une
lettre ouverte du philosophe michel
onfray
revenant sur cette photo polémique
filant de façon explicite la métaphore
sexuelle
je voudrais vous faire réagir sur une
décision qui a été prise par une chaîne
de télévision publique france 5 en
l'occurrence et la présentatrice d'une
de ses émissions marina carrère
d'encausse de ne pas inviter michel
onfray à la suite de cette de ceux de
cette attitude
michel onfray lui se défend en disant
mais j'ai le droit moi aussi à la satire
écoutez il était ce matin sur ses news
parce qu'on a le droit d'être charlie
quand on est philosophe
est ce qu'on a le droit de faire ce que
par exemple font les dessinateurs de
siné de charlie hebdo le canard enchaîné
quand on est philosophe c'est à dire
utiliser une tradition qui est celle de
la satire alors pour lancer le débat je
propose de prendre connaissance de cette
déclaration d'un monsieur qui s'appelle
christian gerin vous savez sans doute
pas qui c'était moi non plus c'est
l'ancien producteur du magazine de la
santé donc l'émission de france 5 dont
michel onfray a été déprogrammée et
voilà ce qu'il dit j'ai appelé marina
carrère d'encausse pour lui dire tu
déconnes à plein tube
je trouve le texte de michel onfray
graveleux et de mauvais goût mais c'est
au tribunal de juger s'il est homophobe
c'est lamentable de les commander pour
ces raisons de quel droit on sent sur un
philosophe on est un peu là sur la
question de principe l'au delà de cette
polémique
est-ce qu'on censure est ce qu on ne
censure pas marin de viry
alors j'ai lu enfin plus exactement j'ai
écouté le message vidéo qu'il a une dans
son entièreté qu'il a fait dans son
entièreté ses logiciels en france celui
michel onfray absolue me a lu sa lettre
sur son sur son compte tout est
absolument absolument savoir que moi je
trouve d'ailleurs point je n'ai pas vu
la moindre trace de mots fleuris
mais peu importe il paraît alors
aujourd'hui j'ai apprécié ce thème là
près de moi ce qui me frappe surtout
avec onfray dans cette affaire c'est que
il a raison de l'hôte et derrière il ya
un problème de deux catégories
moi je ne pense pas qu'on ferait soit un
philosophe au sens où j'appelle
j'appelle les philosophes philosophe si
je peux dire et c'est autre chose c'est
une sorte de commentateurs était bon et
puis il est rentré dans la catégorie des
proches au fond c'est le tribunal des
flagrants délires sa lettre je ne sais
pas si vous l'avez andreu on a
l'impression que celui des proches - les
états forts filet comment dirais-je
cette espèce de lexique formidablement
richer et drôle qu'avec avait des
proches mais bon c'est ça voilà c'est ça
effectivement il file la métaphore
sexuelle et même homosexuel ça c'est
clair oui c'est pas du tout pour autant
homophobes
voilà et je ne vois vraiment pas au nom
de quoi il pourrait y avoir la moindre
censure alors vous vraiment pas au nom
de quoi il pourrait y avait la moindre
sens yonne je ne comprends même pas
l'idée qu'on puisse dire que ceci
engendre une réaction du service public
enfin ou alors on est dans un monde
différentes moi je pense que c'est pts
c'est quand même pour moi c'est une la
photo est une oeuvre d'art avec le
présent la plus française
je vois de gaulle avec un doigt ou
pompidou eca doit voilà avec deux bosses
de deux beaux garçons dépoitraillé et
puis alors dans cette intimité
c'est magnifique c'est un changement
c'est un changement de civilisation
c'est une oeuvre d'art et le texte de
michel onfray en bas c'est l'autre
oeuvre d'art qui répond ah ça oui voilà
à part ça je pense bien sûr on censure
pas non c'est pas ça c'est que l'aspect
tellement peur parce que il peut se
cacher la lettre elle est quand même
elle est terrifiante que les juges
étaient et on me l'a fait lire parce que
enfin on a fait regarder parce que
c'était bien lui et je michel est un ami
et j'étais scotché quand même et je
pense que l'ire présidentielle parce
qu'il peut être rancunier pour la
république canton du fait des blagues de
ce genre et les journalistes ont déjà
peur si l'invitons frais la joueuse elle
il va être il va être éliminé parce
qu'on l'appelle et a une grande culture
alors déjà sa décrue
la france qu'il est 100 ans on le sait
la diffusion je crois que ces
conférenciers qu'on soit sûrs qu'ils
s'arrêtent mais c'est universal la télé
ça c'était avant
voilà donc ça donc france culture a
décidé d'arrêter la diffusion et là
c'est france 5 mai sur une émission qui
est une émission de santé donc il
n'allait pas parler du président de la
république il n'allait pas revenir sur
cette lettre la con lem qu'on n'aime pas
qu'on trouve que le style est un peu
moyen graveleux pas vraiment celui d'un
fils avec un chant et c'est elle qui
devait témoigner de de ceux de l'avc
qu'il avait eu donc donc voilà il devait
parler de ce qui est vrai c'est que le
thon dont frais et légèrement menaçant
elle c'est pour ça qu'il est menaçant et
notamment il revient sur la sphère
benalla sur les zones d'ombré de la
sphère benalla et en disant la galère
financière s'allumant le patrimoine
financier du président de la république
donc il ya toutes sortes de choses qui
sont quand même un j'accuse
oui qui sont avec peu de côté tous les
ans je ne vous accuse sans mots t'es
fait ça oui qu'est ce que vous en pensez
moi je vous le dit fièrement comme
directeur de journal j'aurais pas
publier la lettre dont frais parce que
alors c'était une question de style je
ne savais pas sa place dans le figaro
magazine
est ce que je leur faisais même idée il
aurait invité s'il avait été responsable
d'une démission a été mise en public bah
je sais pas je vous demande votre avis
du coup moi je ne suis pas tellement
un fan de l'écriture et du ton qui a été
employé sur sur cette lettre qu on est
on est d'accord c'est un style qui est
très particulier qui est effectivement
peut-être menaçant mais qui met pas très
à l'aise moi je trouve à la lecture que
c'est plutôt un voilà c'est un peu un
pamphlet mais vraiment alors grossier
graveleux je pense que j'ai raison dans
les mots qu'il emploie est ce que pour
autant ça avoue ça vaut 100 sûr je ne
sais pas d'abord parce que s'est donnée
un peu beaucoup d'importance à celui qui
de fait a écrit a écrit ces mots et ces
phrases et d'autre part c'est vrai que
j'ai l'impression que les deux font la
paire entre la photo initiale et puis le
franc que j'allais dire on est un peu
toujours on est un peu dans le même mode
c'est quelque chose qui marche c'est
quelque chose qui est très étonnant
qu'il n'y a un peu mal à l'aise et si le
niveau du débat sur la photo est à ce
point là alors ça interroge un petit peu
beaucoup dans le moment qu'on traverse
exactement mal à l'aise vous avez quand
on est mal à l'aise quand on voit cette
photo parce qu'en se dit qu'enfin on
croit rêver
on est mal à l'aise quant à la lettre
les fautes boudaya en fait il ya à
l'époque de l'obscénité de poudrière
parler de l'obscénité c'est ce qui est
en dehors de la scène le président est
en dehors de la scène présidentielle et
onfray et en dehors de la scène
philosophie si les deux réponses cherche
encore quelques réactions d'internautes
babineau qui nous dit c'est un essai
satirique délibérément provocateur
accusés on ferait d'homophobie c'est la
meilleure façon de le faire taire anti
mac nous dit l'essentiel c'est la
liberté de parole on ne va quand même
pas traîner tout le monde en justice et
puis il ya cette réflexion que je livre
à votre commentaire zemmour onfray
taddei on vire les opposants pour ce
qu'il ya une volonté de virer ceux qui
pensent pas bien richard blade eric
zemmour c'est parce qu'il a été
déprogrammé à on n'est pas couché
l'émission de laurent ruquier
je ne sais pas ils pensent tous quand
même un petit peu de la même manière ce
conte
ce que vous citez n'ont ils sont enfin
je sais pas j'ai pas cette impression
qui est une volonté de il ya une
tendance un petit peu qui est paradoxal
c'est à la fois on a des gens qui dans
le débat public sont de plus en plus
dans l'affirmation dans la revendication
et qui met sur la table des idées qu'il
ya quelques années on n'aurait pas
entendu il ya un espèce de mouvement
aussi de ballades un peu prêt-à-penser
de surtout ne pas sortir d'un
politiquement correct les deux
s'affrontent un peu moi j'ai vraiment
encore l'impression qu'on est dans
quelque chose d'assez stérile et que sur
ce débat on mériterait un petit peu
autre chose j'ai une chose que je
voudrais dire c'est ce dont on parle là
si on avait des systèmes on programme
pas tous les ans tous les dix ans tous
les 20 ans les mêmes à la télé peut-être
qu'on se poserait pas cette question ça
fait combien de temps que zemmour et sur
les ondes bas ont peut-être changé il ya
peut-être d'autres gens à écouter
d'autres intellectuels est vrai d'autres
philosophes des vrais entendre que ce
lapin qui fait la liste c'est celle oui
c'est ça
je sais que vos questions ce je pense
qui fait la vie ce qui fait le succès
des bons des piqûres qui fait de ce
livre rien de sûr la démarche représente
public voulait justement instaurer un
espèce de groupe de réflexion et les
législations là dessus mara dernier
dernier mot mais juste y un surmoi du
journalisme de service public qui est à
réinventer c'est évident qui fait la
liste c'est une excellente question
eh bien on restera sur cette excellente
question posée par périco légasse qui
fait la liste point de vue ça revient
demain avec mariam les lombards qui fait
la liste des invités c'est nous et on
assume assez bien merci beaucoup de
votre fidélité à demain bonsoir
[Musique]